P youtubers happy Star Wars Friday you
guys requested a bin Jedi video so here
we go we have to talk about bins
awakening and becoming a potential
future Jedi there are some clues based
on rogue one and actually the rogue one
blu-ray giveaways so going on all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video I'll
announce a new winner at the end of this
but the really important line of
dialogue and the idea of ambiguity and
Star Wars was when Snoke was talking to
kylo Ren and said there has been an
awakening have you felt it now in the
most literal sense he was referring to
Rey because she ended the movie with
Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber seeking
out Luke Skywalker to develop her
affinity for the force and become a
potential future Jedi or whatever new
type of training Luke Skywalker's going
to give her she is the Jedi of the
movies but she is not the only force
sensitive person in the movies in the
things that we've learned from a Leia
storyline in all the movies the expanded
Canon is that she was every bit as force
sensitive as a Luke and had the
potential to become a Jedi but
circumstances letter to lead the life of
a politician and now a general so it is
not something that she ever pursued
everyone was asking the Star Wars people
when force awakens came out why in 30
years has Leia never trained to become a
Jedi because it's understandable why she
wouldn't pursue forced training
immediately after learning that Luke was
her brother
they were the remains of the empire to
defeat there was this great battle she
had to form the New Republic there were
so many practical problems in healing
the galaxy that she just felt like she
had too many responsibilities and then
when she started a family with Han Solo
that became a much bigger thing but the
idea of becoming a Jedi was very
important to her so that's why she sent
kylo Ren to train with Luke at a very
early age but that's kind of another
story that deals with kylo Ren
abandonment issues and how Snoke bound
him being on the other hand if you
haven't read them before the awakening
book it was sort of like the preamble
for Star Wars The Force awakens they
dealt with the main characters finn rey
poe and told you a little bit about what
was happening to them in their early
lives and it just talks about how finn
was taken as a child by the first order
in conditioned over time so all these
stormtroopers that you see here the
first order troopers were conditioned
from birth so they all have this really
high level of brainwashing about them so
that they can go about their daily lives
but they are completely in tune with the
first orders line of thought and as you
find out through phasma's character
through the movie it's very rare for
storm troopers to break their
conditioning so something special
happened inside finn sn2 on 8 7 reported
night vision welcome al you ated and
central reconditioning no prior signs of
nonconformity this was his first and
this is where we get into rogue one step
so during rogue one we travel to jetta
we learn all about the history of the
jedi there it was this really cool
addition to the canon Kyber crystals
everywhere the guardian of the Wills
chroot was very force sensitive but as
far as we know never actually trained to
become a Jedi although he probably
trained in forced practices because if
you remember the Church of the force
then you're going to be studying things
about the four if you treat it like a
religion so you know all about their
practices but you may not have any
practical training as a Jedi even though
you have combat training as we saw in
the film he was a total badass it was
great with that special bow caster with
the Kyber crystal inside it so when he's
chanting I am one with the force and the
forces with me and he's holding his bow
caster there with the Kyber crystal he
sort of utilizing the force in a really
low-level way that you know people
always wonder about Han Solo - that's
another example whereby he calls a lot
of his piloting skills luck and while he
is highly skilled as a pilot a lot of
people even Lucasfilm story group people
say that he might just be using the
force in a really low-level way without
realizing it just because he doesn't
believe in it doesn't mean that it
doesn't exist so obviously old Han Solo
totally believes in the force but we're
talking about young Han Solo
a bunch of mumbo-jumbo magical power
Holding together good and evil that our
rational life crazies is India the big
one was this deleted Maz Kanata scene
that made it onto the blu-ray so we know
very little about maz kanata's character
only that she's very old she's kind of
the Yoda type figure in the movie
someone small who looks kind of like a
muppet but has great knowledge of the
force in a really mysterious past so
when the first order attacks it just
reduces the cantina to rubble you see
her using the force to lift a giant
piece of building off of her so we know
that she's force sensitive he knows how
to wield the force but there's no
evidence that she's ever been a Jedi
during her life but she just has great
knowledge of the force so that'll just
continue out in the new film so look
forward to a lot of Maz Kanata stuff
happening in episode 8 in episode 9 and
even though they sort of cut past it
really quickly she did make it out when
the resistance and Leia came to rescue
all those people after the first order
and left so Maz Kanata is still very
much part of the franchise in a good
example of someone who is force
sensitive and can use the force without
being a Jedi so in that way
finn is able to use a lightsaber because
it's a piece of machinery you don't have
to be force sensitive to activate anakin
skywalker's lightsaber but in this
moment with kylo ren this final fight he
does have a daisy ridley rey type moment
where he sort of focuses himself and is
able to hold him off for a couple blows
till of course the much more skilled
kylo ren cuts him down I know everybody
had all kinds of stuff to say about that
final fight between Rey and kylo Ren the
way the producers talked about it it was
meant to have been a leveled playing
field somewhat like she was able to
fight him off because he was gravely
wounded but they didn't do the best job
of conveying that with him just you know
feeding his chest there but no matter
how weak he was there was no way that
Finn with even less force sensitivity
that Rey was going to beat him in a
fight but bringing it back around to
chroot Donnie yen's character he was
able to use the Force to do something
really great escape all that blaster
fire in this open field like he should
have been cut down in seconds but you
could also look at that as sort of a
funny way of them sewing up some of the
stormtrooper being tear
durable with blasters logic like if you
pointed them at the broadside of a Star
Destroyer they wouldn't be able to hit
it with a blaster that's how bad
original trilogy stormtroopers are in
for the most part during the new movies
even though then has some force
sensitivity it doesn't necessarily mean
he's going to jump to any sort of force
training but I do think eventually like
when you look at the history of the
original trilogy characters Luke Leia
odd in the things that they did over
their lifetimes he'll get there
eventually the whole idea of episode 7
was is the force was awakening all over
the place not just in Ray's character
that's why titles are ambiguous like
when you say the last Jedi title is very
ambiguous is it talking about Rick is it
talking about Luke
so they totally do that on purpose so
Finn has his awakening moment even
though it seems more like his morality
is awakening there's a lot more that's
going on in this scene
[Music]
based on that clip that they screen the
other day at the Disney shareholders
meeting - we also saw Finn in a uniform
like an imperial uniform standing on the
bridge of a first-order Star Destroyer
with Captain phasma in the background so
it just confirms first-order infiltrator
storyline so whatever raised training
storyline with Luke is going to be her
learning about the force in a much more
specific context sin will be mostly
focused on the day-to-day of the
resistance in trying to find out what
the first orders next move is so in real
life the actor John boyega has been
posting stuff like not all heroes wear
capes making it seem like he's not going
to become a Jedi but that doesn't mean
that he's not force sensitive
or does not have the potential to become
a Jedi so I think that was one of the
greatest things that rogue one did is
that it sort of brought in the context
of the force and said that people can
use the force without being a full-blown
Jedi because the whole idea is if the
Jedi are super rare now so if everybody
started using lightsabers it would be
way less special and that doesn't mean
that that's the last time that finn is
ever going to hold a lightsaber in his
hand so here's my big question for you
guys when do you think that finn is
going to use the force consciously or
unconsciously next in the future so
think of it in a very low level Donnie
Yen type way just focusing his Chi
acting calmly although when you look at
the characters from the force awakens he
was sort of the reactor he was the one
that was going crazy with all this stuff
going on so it sounds like he's gonna
have to learn to center himself if he's
going to learn to be an infiltrator in
the first order because I am so excited
to watch Basma just take nobody [ __ ] she
was one of the coolest boba fett style
characters that you saw so little of
that's why I got really excited when I
heard that finn might be thrown back
into her proximity through his storyline
so let me know what you think is
happening with ben and what it's going
to take for him to start pursuing more
Force training before Finn starts
thinking about the force in a more
specific context like I would go crazy
if he actually said that Donnie Yen line
I am one with the force
the forces with me that would be a great
way to circle it back around and tie in
the old stuff without actually doing
rogue one
stuff during the new movies so I should
also say big you know big news is that
Star Wars rebels was renewed for season
four they're going to give the first
preview at Star Wars Celebration so
whenever that drops I'll totally do a
trailer video for it so yay for Star
Wars rebels but let me know in the
comments what you want me to do for my
next Star Wars bonus video in what's
happening tomorrow is is this brand new
Wonder Woman dropping so I'll do a video
for that trailer and then they announced
a new Avengers infinity war character
it's going to be part of Santos's
obsidian order so that is crazy so I
will try to get that stuff out as fast
as possible but congratulations to this
week's Star Wars giveaway winners
stinger drawers please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details new round
started in this video I'll just announce
the winner the next time I post a Star
Wars video where you wait for that click
here for that Game of Thrones season 7
trailer and click here to learn more
about that less Jedi footage thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video me
me me me me anything
[Music]